thierry clair bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors vous
avez été reçu ce matin vous avez
participé à cette réunion avec gérald
darmanin
que s'est-il dit pour retenir de ces
échanges écoutez tout d'abord le
ministre a porté nous a fait part kg et
qu'il apportait son soutien aux
policiers et aux personnels du ministère
de l'intérieur
c'était quand même aussi important de
l'entendre de sa part même si on avait
pas de sujet là dessus en ce qui
concerne notamment les discussions
préalables que nous avions eue
l'annnonce du bureau de la sécurité
l'unsa-police donc aurait fermé bien sur
ses positions et le ministre nous a
assez engagé en tout cas sur notamment
une partie du volet social du protocole
de 2016 savoir la gratuité par exemple
dans les transports pour les personnels
de police la prise en compte d'une
partie de la complémentaire santé pour
l'unsa police qui était important
également il s'agit de la protection
fonctionnelle des policiers notamment
contre la diffusion malveillante des
images de visages de policiers et le
ministre en tout cas même si la loi
aujourd'hui est toujours en discussion
au parlement entre le sénat l'assemblée
nationale
en tout cas nous a fait part que
l'exécutif et que lui-même soutenait en
tout cas cette demande alors que
l'article 24 bien sûr et en réécriture
mais qu' il s'inscrivait pleinement dans
dans cet article dans cette
dans cette demande en tout cas qui qui
nous paraît nous importante est-ce que
vous sortez est satisfait de cette
réunion a coûté satisfait sur le
discours j'irai oui
par contre nous attendons un courrier le
ministre s'est engagé à nous fournir un
courrier en début de semaine lundi ou
mardi et le contenu de ce courrier
devrait en tout cas faire état de
l'ensemble des engagements qu'il a pris
que l'état en tous cas souhaite mettre
en place et à ce niveau-là l'unsa-police
réunira ensuite ses instances pour
décider puisque nous avons conditionner
notre présence ou non participation aux
bobos annoncée de la sécurité par
rapport justement à la concrétisation et
des éléments en tout cas tangible
concernant les différents protocoles
signés auparavant ont différentes
mesures qui était importante et attendue
par les personnels donc ça veut dire que
vous allez peut-être participer à ce
beau vos de la sécurité écoutez notre
nous en discuterons avec l'ensemble de
notre conseil national après avoir lu
attentivement je dirais le courrier
puisque les engagements bien sûr seront
tout cas porté par écrit les engagements
du ministre est en tout cas c'est en
fonction effectivement du contenu que
nous prononcerons et que nos instances
en tout cas seront amenés à se prononcer
donc des engagements au niveau du volet
social mais qu en est il par rapport à
la colère des policiers par rapport à
l'interview d'emmanuel map rond qui a
parlé de violences policières à deux
contrôles au faciès que c'était lié ce
propos là en ce qui concerne les bons
pour nous ce qui est important
d'une part c'est d'avoir un soutien je
tairai inconditionnels bien sûr de
l'état inconditionnel dans le cadre bien
sûr du respect des textes du respect des
textes de la république mais qu'on ne
soit pas dans un discours à géométrie
variable nous avons fait part au
ministre de l'intérieur du désarroi des
collègues de des fonctionnaires de
police qui aujourd'hui sont désabusés
par rapport aux différents discours qui
sont entendus de part et d'autre sans
proférer de part et d'autre et que les
policiers avaient besoin véritablement
de sérénité c'est pour cette raison que
le ministre nous a présenté en tout cas
les grandes lignes d'un ce qui pourrait
être un bourreau de la sécurité nous en
tout cas avant même de se prononcer sur
une participation ou non sur notamment
la place du policier le soutien de
l'état bref qu'on puisse évoquer toutes
ces choses là de façon très sereine
ce qui nous paraît important quand même
c'est que les engagements de l'état sur
la protection du policier notamment d'un
cadre de la protection fonctionnelle
soit véritablement tout nu et la loi
justement sur la sécurité à global quant
à la sécurité des des policiers est ce
que ça vous semble judicieux écoutez
dieu nous avons été nous avions été
auditionné en tout cas avant même la
laddh issue des discussions engagées
dans le cadre de la proposition de loi
il ya un certain nombre de sujets qui
ont été retenus qui ont été pris en
compte d'autres non mais notamment en ce
qui concerne alors aujourd'hui l'article
24 qui fait bien sûr le bouc le couler
beaucoup d'encre qui doit être soumis à
une réécriture pour nous ce qui est
important en tout cas et bien ta ble
ment vraiment très important c'est de
lutter contre la diffusion d'image
malveillante de policiers on ne peut pas
en rester là sa place nos collègues en
insécurité permanente e et des membres
de
famille donc il faut vraiment qu'on
légifère sur ce sur ce thème là le
ministre en tout cas apporté son soutien
est ce que tous les syndicats policiers
gendarmes sont unis face au ministre de
l'intérieur le ministre d'intérieur a
reçu ce matin les organisations
syndicales les unes après les autres
chacun puisse exprimer je pense qu'en
tout cas et c'est pour cette raison
d'ailleurs que le courrier qui va nous
envoyer gérer sera important puisque
mois nous pourrons nous positionner sur
l'ensemble des discussions qui ont été
posées par les uns et par les autres et
que en tout cas ce positionnement en
tout cas sera générale en ce qui nous
concerne ce que nous souhaitons bien sûr
c'est que il faut pas oublier que nous
sommes là pour un unsa police c'est ce
que nous avons en ligne de mire c'est
que nous sommes là pour la défense des
personnels pour la défense des policiers
avant toute chose et que je veux dire
quelles que soient les boutiques que
syndical qui puisse exister
véritablement notre positionnement se
fasse j'irai dans l'intérêt général
bien sûr de nos collègues encadre
également de nos institutions
thierry clair merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions nous rappelle que vous
êtes délégué syndical unsa police et que
vous avez participé ce matin à la
réunion avec le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin mais retief